I know that you were close to Chester  Bennington and losing him yesterday it  was a hard thing for the music world  yeah you thought it was pretty uh you  know I mean we had been with him in the  studio a couple months ago and he seemed  in good spirits so when I heard the news  for me personally he just got a stay of  me I was driving and remember calling  welders like dude I can't believe this  you know we just the studio with us and  we built a friendship with him which is  even harder when he built the friendship  outside of working with each other yeah  so our hearts and condolences go to his  family into Lincoln Park all right one  last thing to end on upbeat note are you  also are you still dancing like you  dance are used to moving like you move  are you still I still got it  you still got that  [Music]